CONGRESS TO GET BACK TO WORK AS
EVERYONE ELSE IS TRYING TO GET
BACK TO WORK, HOUSE MINORITY
LEADER KEVIN McCARTHY.
MAYBE I’M READING THIS WRONG BUT
PEOPLE ARE PASSIONATE NOW.
THEY HAVE ASSESSED THIS VIRUS,
THEY HAVE ASSESSED THE SHUTDOWN,
A LOT OF LIVES WERE SAVED.
THE MEASURES HAD BEEN
EXTRAORDINARY, MEDICAL
MOBILIZATION THAT WILL BE
STUDIED FOREVER, WHAT DO YOU
THINK ABOUT WHAT’S GOING ON
HERE?
OR SOMETHING BUILDING AND IT
SEEMS REAL.
>> AMERICANS ALWAYS CRAVE THEIR
OWN LIBERTY IN THEIR OWN
FREEDOM.
IT’S INTERESTING WITH
GOVERNOR GAVIN NEWSOM’S
DECISION, WHY DID HE PICK
ORANGE COUNTY?
THIS IS SOME OF THE BEST BEACHES
IN THE ENTIRE COUNTRY.
HUNTINGTON BEACH, SURF CITY USA.
SOME OF THE BEST LIFEGUARDS.
THE LOCAL CITY COUNCIL ACTUALLY
VOTED TO ALLOW THEM TO OPEN UP
IN A SAFE MANNER.
WHEN I LOOK AT THOSE PROTESTERS,
WHERE YOUR MASKS, PRACTICE
SOCIAL DISTANCING, WE SHOULD DO
SOMETHING EVEN BETTER IN THIS
PROCESS BUT WE CAN OPEN UP IN A
SAFE MATTER MOVING FORWARD AND
THAT’S WITH THE CITIES ARE
ASKING FOR.
LET THEM HAVE LOCAL CONTROL JUST
AS THE PRESIDENT GAVE GOVERNORS
THE ABILITY TO HAVE LOCAL
CONTROL AS WELL.
WHY WOULDN’T HE HONOR THAT WITH
CITIES KNOWING BEST?
>> Sean: THE PERSON WHO’S
HANDLED THIS THE BEST IS
RON DeSANTIS, HIGH ELDERLY
POPULATION, TARGETED THEM.
NEW YORK A DISASTER.
GAVIN NEWSOM DID A LOT BETTER
THAN NEW YORK AND MICHIGAN BY
FAR.
>> I WAS ON THE PHONE WITH HIM
YESTERDAY AND I THANKED HIM FOR
HOW HE WORKED WITH THE PRESIDENT
AND THE PRESIDENT WORKING WITH
HIM.
IT WAS A GOOD EXAMPLE.
I WATCH THE PRESIDENT TALK WITH
HIM TODAY ABOUT THIS PRESS
CONFERENCE WITH THE GOVERNOR OF
NEW JERSEY PRICING HIM TELLING
HIM THANK YOU FOR GETTING ALL OF
THOSE VENTILATORS,
LIFE-AND-DEATH SITUATIONS, THE
PRESIDENT MOVING A NAVY SHIP
HERE FOR A HOSPITAL JUST LIKE
YOU DID IN NEW YORK, AMAZING
THINGS WE HAVE DONE.
THE THING THAT WE CAN DO, WE ARE
TALKING ABOUT A BEACH INSIDE THE
HEAT, THIS IS NOT A GOOD PLACE
FOR THE VIRUS TO LIVE BUT IF
THOSE ON THE BEACH CAN PRACTICE
SOCIAL DISTANCING JUST LIKE YOU
SAW IN THAT VIDEO THAT THEY
WERE, I THINK WE CAN OPEN SOME
UP AND LET THE LOCALS CONTROL
HOW WE GO ABOUT DOING THAT.
>> Sean: 187 DAYS,
DONALD TRUMP SAVED NEW YORK, NO
POLITICIAN IN NEW YORK DID.
>> CONGRESS NEEDS TO GET BACK TO
WORK.
THE THING I WOULD TELL YOU HIS
DOCTORS, DELIVERY DRIVERS,
DISPATCHERS, THEY ARE ALL
WORKING TO END THIS PANDEMIC BUT
THE DEMOCRATS ARE NOT.
THE ELECTION IS COMING UP,
PEOPLE NEED TO TAKE THE HOUSE
HOUSE.COM TO WORK WITH THIS
PRESIDENT.
WHAT YOU TALKED ABOUT WITH FLYNN
AND THE PRESIDENT IS BIGGER THAN